[Musique]
de nombreux éboulements obstruer les
routes départementales suite au passage
de la tempête carlos les routes les plus
impactés sont traditionnellement les
route de salazie et de cilaos et comme
souvent après les cyclones la sécurité
des usagers restent la priorité
donc aujourd'hui on va faire une
inspection héliportés pour faire le tour
des différents points un peu sensible où
on a eu des événements sur les trois
derniers jours on peut nous des fortes
pluies
les conditions météo n'ont pas permis de
faire cette inspection plus tôt on le
fait aujourd'hui
donc on va faire le tour de cinq points
sur salazie et trois ou quatre points
sur cilaos voir s'il n'y a pas de risque
qu'on n'a pas vue depuis la route qui
pourrait nécessiter un traitement la
direction départementale des routes
mobilise ce jour là le brgm ainsi qu'une
entreprise spécialisée
des spécialistes de nos reliefs qui
inspectent méticuleusement les falaises
au dessus et en dessous des routes
si l'os n'étant que de l'autre côté du
piton des neiges
l'inspection se fait le jour même
l'accès à l'île est à cordes est une
route départementale régulièrement
fréquenté on va survoler la pente
on l'apprend parle alors de 4,5 il ya
des couples qui se départager entre le
entre le filet on travaille tu es
d'accord entre le filet puis le pont
bois rouge
[Musique]
suite à la visite donc on a vu les
différents points où on a eu des
événements donc ce qui en ressort c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de grosses masses en
attente urgente mais par contre de
l'entretien à faire avant les prochaines
puis s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas de blog
puisse partir avec d'autres évènements
que ça ça va être fait dès la semaine
prochaine
vincent réalisé avec les équipes voilà
une action méconnu des agents du
département
de quoi assurer la sécurité et le
confort des usagers des 720 km de routes
départementales dont 420 de route de
montagne
[Musique]